mais il est vraiment injustement frappé
par les effets du changement climatique
[Musique]
la lutte contre le dérèglement
climatique en République démocratique du
Congo se matérialise notamment par
l'engagement de la jeunesse il y a de
plus en plus de jeunes qui prennent
conscience du fait que le changement
climatique il est réel et vu que RDC la
population est majoritairement jeune bah
les jeunes ils ont une influence soir
les le reste de la communauté par
exemple avec l'association faniaque j'ai
créé on y sait travailler dans les
quartiers dans les écoles pour que les
gens ils changent cette perception du
changement climatique et que les gens
ils sont en compte qui se rendent compte
que le problème il est réel et qu'il
faut qu'on agisse en conséquence par
exemple quand on a commencé à travailler
avec les bases de rapport dans le
quartier les gens ils sont des pas
vraiment compte ça veut dire qu'on sait
qu'il y a les inondations et que c'est
dû à cause du fait qu'on jette par
exemple nos déchets dans les caniveaux
et qu'après l'eau annule par où passer
mais il savait pas forcément que on
pouvait changer notre manière de voir et
de faire des choses et nous de temps en
temps les gens ils se disent mais oui
mais vous avez raison il faut qu'on
change et ça c'est l'exemple que ce que
nous les jeunes adolescents on peut
apporter au reste de la communauté
[Musique]
le problème c'est que nos gouvernements
par exemple s'engage énormément ils
prennent beaucoup de d'engagements
internationaux mais qu'ils appliquent
pas réellement et donc ça servirait à
rien de toujours ratifier des
compressions qui vont rester sur papier
alors que sur le terrain il y a un réel
besoin par exemple avoir d'essayer la
loi sur l'importation et la fabrication
de plastique qui est interdite en
République démocratique du Congo mais
1500 tonnes de déchets plastiques
produits chaque année ça prouve que
cette loi elle est pas prise elle est
pas mise en application
[Musique]
déjà il faut que on est tous un même
accès à l'éducation climatique il faut
déjà que ce soit quelque chose qui qui
soit mise en avant qu'à l'école on
apprenne que c'est réel qu'on vivra pas
comme en 2004 par exemple qu'il va faire
beaucoup plus chaud on doit apprendre à
mieux construire nos maisons à adopter
par exemple une maison d'inondation ça
c'est des choses qu'on devrait apprendre
dans les universités dans les écoles
mais aussi en fait former des relais
dans les communautés et avoir ce langage
qui arrive à mettre ensemble de les
liens entre la crise climatique et tous
les problèmes sociaux économiques par
exemple déjà ils vont te dire clairement
que en fait nous on a pas de travail on
mange pas bien on vit pas bien et donc
les problèmes d'or climatiques c'est les
cadets de nos soucis il faut que les
jeunes ils se rendent compte qu'en fait
le changement climatique a un impact
sont notre éducation sont la survie sur
la participation sur notre développement
et même sur nos capacités à pouvoir
voilà nous faire un peu d'argent à la
fin du mois par exemple et que en
fonction de tout ça les pousser à
s'engager avec ce message qui va être
voilà dans les langues nationales
adaptées à toutes les couches de sens à
toutes les couches de la population par
exemple
[Musique]
aussi sur les autres questions